find your plus any business that you get
into is going to be ultra competitive
there's a lot of people doing it the way
to stand out the way to be more
successful at the way to make more money
the way to have a greater impact is to
find your plus find what it's unique to
you then you can bring to that company
the sky rocketed success so I've got a
great question from one of my youtube
viewers Glenda love you guys grow it in
the say I love your videos I'm 56 years
old maid I have a crochet hobby I love
it with a passion to turn it into a
business at home but my problem is I
don't know where to start from Glenda
you need to find your plus there's a lot
of people doing crochet what you need to
do is find out what more Glenda you
could bring to that crochet business so
for example if you like designing and
using new materials then you can create
and sell products using an Etsy store if
you like teaching and coaching people
then you can create an e-book or udemy
course if you like being in front of the
camera and speaking then you can launch
a youtube channel and monetize to
advertising there's a lot of different
ways that you can make money from a
crochet business but it's not going to
happen for you until you find your plus
think about another passion another
skill that you could bring to match with
the crochet to build something that is
uniquely glenda and for those are you
watching you need to do the same thing
with your business find something that's
unique to you that you could bring to
your industry merge your passions
together into one business so that
you're the only one doing this in your
industry instead of one of many you'll
find yourself working with more ideal
clients making more money having more
fun and making a much greater impact so
find your place and believe those are
you watching I'd love to know what your
plus is leave it in the comments below I
look forward to the discussion i'm going
to join in there with you guys I maybe
even share the journey of how you found
your plus and what you're doing to get
there and of course if you liked this
video you want to see more just like it
remember to subscribe to the channel
thank you guys are watching I'll see you
soon even your new little bit totally
not secret I look forward to them Avery
they have changed my life thank you
you